Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. 7th April 1944. After days of delay, weeks of obsessive preparation, months of watching the failed attempts of others and two years of seeing the depths to which human beings could sink, the moment had finally come. It was time to escape.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及深受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1944年4月7日。经过数日的耽搁、数周的苦心筹备、数月来对他人失败尝试的冷眼旁观，以及两年来看尽人类堕落之底线后，那个时刻终于来临了。是时候逃跑了。
The two other prisoners were already there at the designated spot. Wordlessly, they gave the nod, do it now. Walter and Fred did not hesitate. They climbed on top of the timbers, found the opening, and one after the other, they dropped inside. A second later, their comrades moved the planks into place above their heads. One of them whispered, bon voyage, and then all was dark and silent. Dominic, that is the completely gripping opening to Jonathan Friedland's book, The Escape Artist, about Rudolf Verbe, the man who escaped Auschwitz.
另外两名囚犯已经等在指定地点了。他们无声地给了一个眼神，就是现在。沃尔特和弗雷德没有犹豫。他们爬上木料堆，找到了洞口，然后一个接一个地跳了进去。一秒钟后，他们的战友把木板移回了头顶上方。其中一人低声说了句“一路顺风”，随后四周便陷入了一片黑暗与死寂。多米尼克，这就是乔纳森·弗里德兰（Jonathan Friedland）关于鲁道夫·韦尔巴（Rudolf Verba）——那个逃出奥斯威辛的男人——的书《逃亡艺术家》（The Escape Artist）中极其引人入胜的开篇。
And the Holocaust is a subject that we haven't yet really done in depth on. The rest is history. But if ever there was a way into that darkest of subjects, Jonathan Friedland's book is it. It is, absolutely. It is. Hello, everybody. Yes, I read this book last spring when it came out. And that opening scene unforgettable so the book's editor at the sunday time said to me would you like to review this book
而大屠杀是我们至今尚未在《历史的 rest》中进行过深入探讨的主题。但如果要寻找一个切入这个最黑暗主题的方式，乔纳森·弗里德兰的书绝对是最佳选择。确实如此，绝对是。大家好。是的，去年春天这本书出版时我读了。开篇的那一幕令人难忘，当时《星期日泰晤士报》的书籍编辑对我说，你愿不愿意写一篇书评
which is about somebody who escaped from auschwitz and i have to say i'm ashamed to say i i didn't know that anybody had ever escaped um from auschwitz i thought it was a place you went and basically you didn't come back. So I didn't know this story at all. It is the most extraordinary story, partly because of the escape. So he does make it out, there's the spoiler, but also because what he compiled was the most haunting and incredibly detailed account of what life was like hour by hour, day by day inside the extermination camp. And I'd never read anything quite like it, I have to say. So we're hugely honoured to have Jonathan with us. Jonathan, Guardian columnist,
关于某个逃离奥斯威辛的人，我必须说，我很羞愧地承认，我以前不知道竟然有人能从奥斯威辛逃出来。嗯，我以为那是那种一旦进去基本上就再也回不来的地方。所以我对这个故事一无所知。这是一个极其非凡的故事，部分原因在于这场逃亡。剧透一下，他的确成功逃出来了，但同样因为他整理出了一份极其震撼、细节惊人的记录，记录了集中营内部每时每刻、每天的生活状况。我必须说，我从未读过类似的书。因此，我们非常荣幸能请到乔纳森作客。乔纳森，《卫报》专栏作家，
presenter of The Long View, a rival history on Radio 4, novelist. And Jonathan, this really, I guess, is your first work of history. You've written a memoir before, a family memoir, going through the 20th century, but this is the first book that you've written focused on a particular episode in history. And I guess the drama, the extraordinary character of the story is what persuaded you to start writing it. I think that's right. I was quite daunted by the idea of wading in to history. Even being on this show, quite daunting prospect. It's very good to be here though with both of you. But no, I was new to this. I'm a journalist as my day job and writing about the contemporary world. But something about this story has nagged at me for a very long time, actually. I mentioned in the book at the start that I had had this story
BBC第四台历史节目《长远视角》（The Long View）的主持人、小说家。乔纳森，我想这确实是你的第一部历史著作。你以前写过回忆录，一本关于20世纪的家族回忆录，但这是你第一本专注于历史特定片段的书。我想，正是这个故事的戏剧性和非凡角色说服你开始动笔的吧。我想是的。对于涉足历史领域，我感到挺畏惧的。甚至能来参加这个节目，也是一个相当令人生畏的前景。不过很高兴能和你们两位在这里。但没错，我对这行是个新手。我的本职工作是记者，主要写当代世界。但这个故事中的某些东西实际上已经纠缠了我很长时间。我在书的开篇提到过，我有这个故事
in there since I was 19 years old, because I had seen this extraordinary man, Rudolf Werber, appear in an extraordinary film, actually, the documentary film Shoah, Claude Lansman's nine and a half hour epic of the Holocaust. A film which actually is so unusual because there's no archive in it, there's only contemporary, as they were then, interviews with people who had witnessed the killing process. And one of the standout interviews interviews the man who sort of explodes onto the screen um is this man rudolf verba who to my 19 year old eyes looked a generation younger and in a way was than everyone else on this film this procession of old broken men as it seemed to me because he was what he was 18 when he goes there well he was 17 when he arrived he was 19 when he goes there? Well, he was 17 when he arrived. He was 19 when he escaped. So he was
已经留在心里很久了，自从我19岁起，因为我曾看到这个非凡的男人鲁道夫·韦尔巴出现在一部非凡的纪录片中，实际上就是克劳德·兰兹曼（Claude Lanzmann）那部长达九个半小时的大屠杀史诗纪录片《浩劫》（Shoah）。这部电影非常罕见，因为它没有任何历史档案影像，只有当时（也就是采访发生时）对大屠杀亲历者的采访。其中一个最引人瞩目的采访，那个仿佛在银幕上“爆炸”般的男人，就是鲁道夫·韦尔巴。在我19岁时的眼中，他看起来比这部电影里的其他所有人都年轻整整一代，某种程度上也确实如此。在我看来，电影里其他人都是一排弯腰驼背的老头子，因为他当时——他去那里时几岁？好吧，他到那里时是17岁，他逃跑时是19岁。好吧，他到那里时是17岁。
really a generation younger. But it showed even years later when he's interviewed by Landsman, he has this full head of dark, lustrous, thick hair. He's speaking in English. He's in New York City. He's wearing this tan leather coat. He looks like Al Pacino in Scarface. Whereas all these other guys are sort of hunched. They're speaking in Polish or Russian or German. They looked like witnesses to something that had happened a long time ago. The point about Werber was he suddenly was somebody from our world, a completely contemporary figure to me in the mid-80s watching this film. And almost as an aside, Landsman mentions that Werber had escaped from Auschwitz.
确实比其他人年轻整整一代。但即使在多年后接受兰兹曼采访时，这也能看出来，他依然拥有一头浓密、乌黑、有光泽的头发。他说着英语，身处纽约市，穿着一件棕褐色的皮大衣。他看起来就像《疤面煞星》里的阿尔·帕西诺。而其他那些人都有点驼着背，说着波斯语、俄语或德语。他们看起来就像是在见证一件很久以前发生的事情。韦尔巴的特别之处在于，他突然成了我们世界里的人，在85年代中期看这部电影的我看来，他是一个完全现代的人物。兰兹曼几乎是顺口提到了韦尔巴曾从奥斯威辛逃脱。
And my reaction was like yours, actually, Dominic, when you said, when the book senator said, you know, somebody escaped from Auschwitz. Sitting there in the cinema, age 19, I thought, what? Stop. You know, even age 19. Tell us a story. Yeah. And I knew even then that, OK, some people escaped from Auschwitz, but Jews didn't escape from Auschwitz. You know, that just didn't happen. The degree of terror in which Jews were held in Auschwitz, how is that even possible? As it happens, Landsman is not particularly interested in that story and doesn't really talk about it much with Werber. He instead gets him to
我的反应和你当时一样，多米尼克，当书的编辑说“有人从奥斯威辛逃出来了”时。坐在电影院里，19岁时，我想，什么？等等。你知道，即使是19岁的时候。给我们讲讲这个故事吧。是的。甚至在那时我也知道，好吧，有些人从奥斯威辛逃跑了，但犹太人是没有逃出奥斯威辛的。你知道，那根本不可能发生。犹太人在奥斯威辛所承受的恐怖程度，这怎么可能呢？碰巧的是，兰兹曼对那个故事并不是特别感兴趣，也没有和韦尔巴多谈论这件事。相反，他让韦尔巴
talk about the fact that he had witnessed so much in Auschwitz because he was there so long. He was there the best part of two years. As you know, the life expectancy of a Jew in Auschwitz was measured in hours, and he had been in there for months and months and months. That's why Landsman wanted to speak to him. But it was this escape which intrigued me and always intrigued me. So Jonathan, we'll come to what it is that Werber sees in, what should we call him, Walter, Rudy, Werber? It's very difficult to know, isn't it? It is, because he was born Walter Rosenberg. He changed his name, but I think let's call him Rudy Rudolf Werber.
谈论他在奥斯威辛见证了那么多事情，因为他在那里呆了很长时间。他在那里呆了近两年。如你所知，犹太人在奥斯威辛的预期寿命是以小时计算的，而他在里面待了整整好几个月。这就是兰兹曼想和他谈话的原因。但正是这场逃亡让我着迷，而且一直让我着迷。所以，乔纳森，我们等会儿来谈谈韦尔巴在——我们该怎么称呼他？沃尔特、鲁迪还是韦尔巴？这很难确定，对吧？确实很难，因为他出生时叫沃尔特·罗森伯格（Walter Rosenberg）。他改过名字，但我想我们还是叫他鲁迪·鲁道夫·韦尔巴（Rudy Rudolf Werber）吧。
Okay, let's call him Rudy then. So we will absolutely come to what Rudy sees in Auschwitz. Incredible details of that. Horrific details, obviously. But first of all, can you tell us how it is that he ends up there? Because again, it's kind of paradigmatic, isn't it, for millions and millions of Jews across occupied Europe? Yes. I mean, when you asked me at the start about why this story, there is something paradigmatic about the Rudy story, which is so many of the big themes of the Holocaust somehow
好吧，那就叫他鲁迪吧。所以我们绝对会谈到鲁迪在奥斯威辛看到了什么。那里面有不可思议的细节。当然，也有可怕的细节。但首先，你能告诉我们他是怎么落到那一步的吗？因为同样地，这在某种程度上具有典型性，对吧，对于被占领的欧洲成千上万的犹太人来说？是的。我的意思是，当你在开头问我为什么选择这个故事时，鲁迪的故事中确实有一些具有典型性的东西，大屠杀的许多重大主题不知为何
come through this one person. And so, for example, one point that I and others are often keen to make is that the Holocaust is not only a German thing. It's a Europe-wide project, and that the first country to deport its Jews, certainly to Auschwitz, was Slovakia, of all places. Even before the Nazis are occupying Slovakia, you have a fascist allied government, meaning a government that's a sort of ally, almost vassal, of Berlin, of Hitler's Berlin, that decides to start, you know, outstripping almost the Nazis in its persecution of Jews. And so Rudolf Werber, then Walter Rosenberg, is a young man, a bright, you know, boy who's been brought up, in effect, by a single mother. His father dies when he's four.
都通过这一个人展现了出来。比方说，我和其他人经常强调的一个观点是，大屠杀不仅仅是德国的事情。这是一个全欧洲范围的项目，而第一个驱逐其犹太人（当然是驱逐到奥斯威辛）的国家，竟然是斯洛伐克。甚至在纳粹占领斯洛伐克之前，你就有一个法西斯同盟政府——这意味着一个作为柏林、希特勒柏林的盟友甚至可以说是附庸的政府——决定开始在迫害犹太人方面几乎超越纳粹。因此，鲁道夫·韦尔巴（当时叫沃尔特·罗森伯格）是一个年轻人，一个聪明的男孩，实际上是由单亲妈妈抚养长大的。他四岁时父亲就去世了。
He's in provincial Slovakia. He shows unusual promise. He's very bright. He's reading newspapers by the time he's two years old. And he's at one of the best elite schools in Bratislava. When he turns up for school in the beginning of the academic year, 1938-39, and he's told, there's no place for you. You're a Jew. You cannot go to school. And, you know, I have the photographs there of him in his sort of high school class in the preceding years. And then suddenly there's a gap. He's not there for that following academic year.
他住在斯洛伐克的一个省城。他表现出了非凡的潜质。他非常聪明，两岁时就能看报纸了。他在布拉提斯拉瓦最好的精英学校之一上学。当他在1938至1939学年初去学校报到时，却被告知：这里没有你的位置。你是个犹太人。你不能上学。而且，你知道，我手头有他前几年在高中班级里的照片。然后突然之间出现了一个空白。接下来的那一学年他不在那里。
His name is sort of erased. And so he and his mother go away from the capital and into a small town where he and the other Jews of the town are barred from school. They have to sort of mooch around, teaching each other, educating each other. But eventually through the door, thudding onto the doormat,
他的名字被抹去了。于是他和母亲离开首都，搬到一个小镇，在那里他和镇上的其他犹太人一样被禁止上学。他们不得不四处闲逛，互相教导、互相教育。但最终，一封指令
comes an instruction to turn up at this place at this time with bags weighing no more than 25 kilograms where you are to be deported. And Rudy's reaction, a reaction that you have throughout his life, is a kind of defiance, which is, well, what the hell are you telling me to do that for? Obviously, I'm not going to do that. I'm Slovak born. I speak Slovak. I'm a Czechoslovak citizen then. No, I'm not going to do it. And he embarks on what would be the first escape. And the reason I partly called the book The Escape Artist is there are many escapes in his life. But even at that stage, there's the hint of a theme that comes through again and again,
沉重地落在了门垫上，要求在指定时间到指定地点报到，携带不超过25公斤的行李，随后将被驱逐出境。而鲁迪的反应——一种贯穿他一生的反应——是一种反叛，也就是：“凭什么？你们凭什么命令我做这种事？我显然不会照做。我是斯洛伐克出生的，我会说斯洛伐克语，我当时是捷克斯洛伐克公民。不，我才不干。”于是他开始了他人生的第一次逃亡。我把这本书命名为《逃亡艺术家》的部分原因，是因为他的人生中经历过多次逃亡。但即便在那个阶段，也已经隐现了一个不断重复的主题，
which is that, of course, most people don't run away or try to escape, do they? Reading the book, it made me think a lot about that classic thing that you're encouraged to do from the moment you first studied this in school. What would you do in this circumstance? And the truth of the matter, I suppose, based on this book and everything we know, is that most of us would actually do nothing. If we got that letter, we would troop along, hoping somehow to telling ourselves that things were going to be all right. But there's something in his, is it in his temperament or just that he's more suspicious, more will be a very big theme, the question of trust and personal trust. He becomes extremely untrusting to the point of being, in the words of his first wife, who I interviewed for the book, found her in the last weeks of her life, age 93. She told me that he was paranoid. And she said, you know, people think Auschwitz made him paranoid. It was surviving
那就是，当然，大多数人并不会逃跑或试图逃跑，对吧？读这本书时，它让我深思那个从你第一次在学校学习这段历史时就被鼓励去思考的经典问题：在这种情况下你会怎么做？而事实的真相是，根据这本书和我们所知道的一切，我们大多数人其实什么都不会做。如果我们收到了那封信，我们就会乖乖听从安排，心存侥幸地告诉自己一切都会好起来的。但他的身上有什么东西——是他的性格，还是他更多疑、更……信任与个人信任的问题将是一个非常大的主题。他变得极度不信任他人，甚至到了他第一任妻子所说的地步——我在她生命最后几周找到了她，当时她93岁，我采访了她。她告诉我他有被迫害妄想症。她说，你知道，人们以为是奥斯威辛让他有了被害妄想症。其实是熬过
Auschwitz that made him paranoid. I think it was being paranoid that helped him survive Auschwitz. But at this stage, he's quite a trusting young man, but he is defiant. And I think the point of youth is something I emphasise a lot in the book, because the evidence of his own life and the other people he encountered was that once you are a bit older and you particularly have dependents, a partner, children, elderly parents look after, the idea of risking everything is unpalatable. You have too many people relying on you and therefore you comply with instructions because to not comply is such a spectacularly dangerous thing to do that people don't take that risk. So you're quite right in defying that instruction that comes through the door in April of 1942 was exceptional. A lot of the other people
奥斯威辛的经历让他有了被迫害妄想症。我认为正是这种多疑帮助他在奥斯威辛活了下来。但在那个阶段，他还是个相当信任他人的年轻人，但他很叛逆。我认为我在书中着重强调了“年轻”这一点，因为他自己以及他遇到的其他人的经历都表明，一旦你年龄稍大一点，特别是有了家属、伴侣、孩子、年迈的父母需要照顾时，孤注一掷的想法是让人难以接受的。有太多人依赖着你，因此你会选择顺从指令，因为不顺从是一件极其危险的事，人们不会去冒这个险。所以你说的很对，在1942年4月勇敢地抗拒那份送到家门口的指令是极其罕见的。他身边的许多人
around him were almost relieved by that because they thought, okay, at last things are about to be resolved and sort of clarified. We've had this daily ratchet of Nuremberg-style laws restricting what we can own, where we can travel, who we can talk to. We've prevented from going to school. We can't own a business. Now we're going to be taken somewhere else. And we can start again. And the yellow star.
对此甚至感到有些解脱，因为他们觉得，好吧，事情终于要有个了结、有个明朗的说法了。我们经历了日复一日的纽伦堡法案式的紧箍咒，限制我们能拥有什么、能去哪里旅行、能和谁说话。我们被禁止上学。我们不能拥有企业。现在我们要被带到别的地方去了。我们可以重新开始。还有黄星。
Yeah. Exactly. Wearing the yellow star, that great symbol that is so potent in the imagination. All of those restrictions have come. There was a feeling that this has to come to a head at some point. And now, OK, we're going to have to start over somewhere else. There's something clarifying about that. I wouldn't say it's a relief.
是的。没错，佩戴黄星，那个在想象中具有如此强大力量的标志。所有的限制都已经到来。当时有一种感觉，这件事总得有个了结。现在，好吧，我们得在别的地方重新开始。这有一种让人清醒的效果。我不会说这是一种解脱，
But people did think, OK, now we know what's happening. And he was exceptional in that. And Jonathan, the reason why they could think that being deported to a Nazi-run concentration camp might in some way be a resolution is because what the Nazis are actually planning is so incomprehensible, right? I mean, Rudy, no matter how smart and paranoid and alert he is, it takes him a long time properly to grasp exactly what it is that Auschwitz is about. Absolutely. They didn't think at that stage in 1942 that nobody was talking about Nazi Iran concentration camps, right? No, there is no hindsight yet. They don't know about that.
但人们确实在想，好吧，现在我们知道发生什么了。而他是这其中的特例。乔纳森，他们之所以会认为被驱逐到纳粹经营的集中营可能在某种程度上算是一个结局，是因为纳粹实际计划的事情是如此不可思议，对吧？我的意思是，鲁迪无论多么聪明、多疑、机警，他也花了很长时间才真正准确地理解奥斯威辛究竟是怎么回事。完全正确。他们在1942年那个阶段根本没想到——当时没有人谈论纳粹集中营，对吧？没有，当时还没有后见之明。他们对此一无所知。
They're being told they're going to be deported to new lives in the East. They think and are told, they don't think this because they are imagining this, they are told that they will be resettled in new communities where they will work, they will have schools, they will be able to live full Jewish lives as a Jewish community. They're advised to take the things they will need to begin new lives, not just pots and pans and blankets, but school books and exercise books for their children. Nobody's talking about camps, and certainly the notion of a Nazi camp is alien to them. No one knows of such a thing because it hasn't happened yet. You know, he doesn't know that. And jumping ahead, he does try this first
他们被告知他们将被驱逐到东方去开始新的生活。他们认为而且被告知——他们不是自己凭空想象出来的，而是被告知——他们将被重新安置在新的社区里，在那里他们可以工作、有学校、能够作为犹太社群过上完整的犹太生活。他们被建议带上开始新生活所需的东西，不仅是锅碗瓢盆和毯子，还有给孩子们的课本和练习本。没有人谈论集中营，而且纳粹集中营的概念对他们来说绝对是陌生的。没有人知道有这种东西，因为在此之前还从未发生过。你知道，他并不知道这一点。而且说句题外话，当第一次驱逐发生时，他确实尝试了第一次逃亡。他被带到一个拘留营，一个斯洛伐克的过境营。他又逃跑了。然后他从那里被带到马伊达内克（Majdanek），那将是一个臭名昭著的死亡集中营。但他当时并不知道。他在那里只待了12天。他们寻找去别处做工的志愿者。有机会在开阔的农田里劳动。他举手说，行，我干这个。
escape when the first deportation comes. He's taken to a detention camp, a transit camp in Slovakia. He escapes again. He's then taken from there to Majdanek, which will become a notorious death camp. He doesn't know that. He's only there 12 days. They look for volunteers to go somewhere else. The opportunity to work in the open farmland. He puts his hand up, says, yeah, I'll do that.
那总比他待在马伊达内克这个垃圾堆里要好。然后他发现自己踏上了开往奥斯威辛的火车。甚至当他在1942年6月的最后一天抵达奥斯威辛时，他又感到宽慰，因为他看到这些砖砌建筑、铺好的小路，比起马伊达内克那些风雨飘摇、单薄简陋的木制营房（在里面会被冻死）来说，这看起来要好一些。嗯，这地方我能应付，你知道的。所以在每个阶段，由于没有人知道“奥斯威辛”这个词意味着什么，他和抵达那里的其他人一样都抱最好的希望。他花了很长时间才恍然大悟。
That's got to be better than this dump that he's in in Majdanek. And he finds himself on a train to Auschwitz. And even when he arrives in Auschwitz on the last day of June of 1942, again, he is relieved because he looks at these brick buildings, these paved paths and things, compared to the flimsy, thin, wooden barracks of Majdanek, where you could freeze to death. Well, this looks like something better. Well, I can work with this, you know. So at each stage, because nobody knows what the word Auschwitz means, he and the other people arriving there hope for the best. And it takes him some time for the penny to drop.
你知道，和所有没有被直接送进毒气室的人一样，他在奥斯威辛被当成奴隶、当成苦力来使用。他被转移到不同的地方，进行着累死累活的体力劳动，建造工业工厂——一个将供德国最大的一些企业集团（如法本公司、西门子等）使用的工厂。他参与建造这些工厂有一段时间，但最终他被分到了一个地方，被狱友们戏称为“带K的加拿大”（Canada with a K）。因为我发现，在那个时期的欧洲人的想象中，特别是中欧和东欧，加拿大被认为是一个街道铺满黄金、流淌着奶与蜜的地方。因此，“加拿大”在奥斯威辛的世界里被称为奥斯威辛的“黄金国”，一个物资极其丰富的地方。那里有吃有喝，还有上等的干邑白兰地、丝绸和钻石，因为这是欧洲犹太人随身携带、企图借此贿赂以求生路的所有财物被集中运到的地方。这里堆满了他们的衣服，如果他们在衣服的缝里藏了一颗微小的钻石，也是被堆放在这里。正是通过在“加拿大”的工作，鲁迪才慢慢恍然大悟，他开始意识到：等等，这里的物品比人还要多。我能看到堆积如山的男装、女装和童装，但这里没有儿童。这到底是怎么回事？后来，他甚至为自己没有更早意识到这一点、花了这么长时间才弄明白——有些被带到这里的犹太人甚至没能成为囚犯，因为他们在抵达后数小时内就被杀害了——而感到尴尬。他花了几个星期才得出这个结论，即使作为奥斯威辛内部的人也是如此。这就是大屠杀的欺骗和否认是多么强烈和有力，
You know, he is used, as all those who weren't immediately sent to the gas chambers, he is used as a slave, as a slave worker in Auschwitz. And he's moved from place to place, backbreaking physical work, building the industrial factories, a plant that will be used by some of Germany's biggest conglomerates, you know, IG Farben and Siemens and so on. He's involved in building those for a while, but he eventually finds himself at this place, which is nicknamed Canada with a K by his fellow prisoners. Because Canada, I discover, in the European imagination of that period, particularly in Central Europe and Eastern Europe, was thought to be a place where the streets were paved with gold, a land flowing with milk and honey. And so Canada was known in the Auschwitz universe as the kind of Eldorado
甚至在奥斯威辛内部也是如此。你身处其中却可能一无所知。我正想问关于这个的问题。你书里有一个令人惊叹的场景：他看到囚犯们从特莱西恩施塔特（Theresienstadt）开来的运输车上下来，他的一名狱友低声对一位衣着得体的捷克犹太母亲说：“你很快就会死了。”因为那是真的，对吧？许多人在短时间内就死了，极大量的人在抵达后几小时内就丧命了。
of Auschwitz, a place where there was just plenty. There was food and drink, but there was also fine cognac, there were silks, there were diamonds, because this was the place where all that the Jews of Europe had brought with them to potentially bribe their way to survival was brought. This is where their clothes were piled up, where if they had smuggled a tiny diamond in the hem of their garment, that's where it was piled. And it was working in Canada that slowly the penny dropped for Rudy, that he began to realize, hang on, there is more stuff here than there are people. I can see piles of men's clothes and women's clothes and children's clothes, but there are no children. So what is exactly going on here? And he would be later on embarrassed by the fact that he had not realized this earlier, that it had taken him a while to clock that there are Jews being brought here who never become prisoners because they are killed within hours of their arrival. It takes him weeks to come to that conclusion, even as somebody inside Auschwitz. That's how intense and energetic the deception, the denial, in a way, of the Holocaust was,
而这位显然出身资产阶级家庭的女性走到一名党卫军军官面前问：“这到底是怎么回事？发生什么了？”党卫军军官回答：“哦，我亲爱的女士，我们是文明人，哪个匪徒对你说了这种话？”然后她就被带走了。接着，那个说这话的家伙也被带走枪决了。所以，这也是一件事——我很尴尬地承认——我之前并没有真正理解。那些到达这里并每天继续乘这些运输车到达的人，他们下火车时毫无概念。我的意思是，火车上甚至没有任何谣言说这就是等待他们的命运。完全正确。我的意思是，著名的诺贝尔和平奖得主、大屠杀幸存者埃利·维瑟尔（Elie Wiesel）曾说过，当他在1944年抵达奥斯威辛时，“奥斯威辛”这个词并没有吓到他们，因为从来没有人——用他的话说——从来没有人想过告诉我们那是什么。要么是完全的无知，而对此我必须把责任非常明确地归咎于压迫者，而不是受害者。纳粹致力于这种欺骗。我是说，他们在每个可能的阶段都对此一丝不苟。你知道，有一件事
even inside Auschwitz. You could be in there and not know. I was just going to ask a question about that. So you have an amazing scene which he sees. Prisoners are getting off a transport from Theresienstadt, and one of his fellow prisoners mutters to this well-dressed Czech Jewish mother, you'll be dead soon. Because that's right, isn't it? A lot of people are dead within, a huge amount of people are dead within hours of arrival.
在每个可能的阶段都做到了一丝不苟。你知道，我认为几乎在流行文化层面上广为人知的一点是，犹太人被告知他们是去洗澡，他们去那里是为了消毒，但实际上淋浴喷头是假的，喷出来的其实是毒气。这是众所周知的。我记得我知道这一点时，还以为这是一个恶毒的笑话，是一个可怕的转折。但这其实是整个事件的核心：从一开始被驱逐时，他们就会看到伪造的明信片，或者是由他们的亲友在胁迫下写下的明信片，上面写着：“这里一切都很好，好极了，我们正在开始新的生活。母亲在这里特别高兴，”某人可能会这样写，而收到信的人就会想：“这很奇怪。我们的母亲十年前就去世了。她为什么这么写？”他们会说，
And the woman, who clearly must have been from a sort of bourgeois family, goes up to an SS officer and says, well, what's all this? What's going on? And the SS officer says, oh, my dear lady, we're civilized people, which gangster said this to you? And then he sort of, she's led away. And then the bloke who said it is taken away and shot. So that again, was something that I, I'm embarrassed to admit, I hadn't really grasped. So that the people who arrive and are continuing to arrive every day on these transports, they're getting off the train, and they have no concept. I mean, there's not even rumours on the trains that this is what awaits them. That's exactly right. I mean, Elie Wiesel, famously the Nobel Peace Prize winner and Holocaust survivor, said that the word Auschwitz didn't terrify them when he arrived
“这里太棒了。我们在这里吃饭，就像天天都在过赎罪日一样。”当然，赎罪日是一个斋戒日。那么这个人究竟想传达什么信息呢？但这已经是所能做到的极限了，因为纳粹的努力就是迫使犹太人去安抚他们在家乡的亲友。他们在抵达驱逐营时被告知要排好整齐的队伍，特别是要说明自己从事什么行业，这样他们在洗澡和消毒后就可以被分配工作。直到毒气室的门槛前，欺骗一直在继续。由于鲁迪在“加拿大”仓库工作之后的下一份工作是在火车站台——纳粹称之为“老犹太人坡道”（Alta Judenramp）上工作——
at Auschwitz in 1944, because nobody had ever, the way he put it, was nobody ever thought to tell us what it was. There was either complete ignorance, which again, I put the blame for that very squarely on the oppressors rather than on the victims. The Nazis were devoted to this deception. I mean, they were meticulous about it at every possible stage. You know, one thing meticulous about it at every possible stage. You know, one thing that I think is known, almost at the level of popular culture, is the notion that they were told, Jews were told they were going in to have a shower, that they were there to be disinfected, but actually instead of the shower heads were fake
看着这些火车抵达，有时一天五列，通常是在深夜，卸下这些毫无概念的犹太囚犯（俘虏们下车时一无所知）。他亲眼看到，在他待在那里的整整两年里，没有一个人——他会说没有一个人——知道奥斯威辛意味着什么，或者有什么样的命运在等着他们。乔纳森，你的书令人不寒栗地生动展现了关于大屠杀的另一个老生常谈的说法，那就是种族灭绝的过程是工业化的。你对每晚有四、五、六列运输车抵达的描述——你极其清楚地指出，他们之所以必须被告知这些谎言，不仅是为了加剧正在发生的虐待狂行径，更是为了确保他们能够被顺利处理。因为很显然，
and that gas emerged instead. That is known. I remember knowing that and thinking it was some kind of sick joke, that it was a sort of macabre twist. It was central to what was going on, that at every stage from beginning, when they were deported, they would be shown fake postcards or postcards that had been written under duress by their relatives and friends, saying, it's all fine here, it's wonderful, we're beginning a new life. Mother is particularly happy here, someone might write, to the recipient who would then think, that's odd. Our mother died 10 years ago. Why is she writing that? They would say,
如果爆发暴动，这不仅会给警卫带来需要开枪射击的问题，还会搞砸整个种族灭绝的流程。我认为，这就是鲁道夫·韦尔巴的伟大见识。这触动了他。他当时还是个青少年。在坡道上工作时他已经18岁了。这正是他所意识到的：他正在见证一个工业化的流程，而这台机器的关键要素、齿轮中的关键部分就是欺骗。这不是附加的额外部分，而是必不可少的。为什么？因为为了让纳粹的流程运转、为了让人员吞吐量正常运转，它必须以平稳、有序的方式进行。那些犹太人必须下火车，他们必须允许自己被编成队列，他们必须经过筛选过程——
you know, it's wonderful. We eat here as if every day is Yom Kippur. Yom Kippur, of course, a fast day. So what message is the person trying to send? But that was the most that could be done because the Nazi effort was to force the Jews to reassure their friends and relatives back home. They were told as they arrived at the deportation camp to get into orderly queues and particularly to say what trade they worked in so they might be allocated work after they'd been showered and disinfected. Right up to the threshold of the gas chamber itself, the deception continued. And Rudy, because his next job after working in Canada, in the warehouse of Canada, was working on the railway platform, the Alta Judenramp, the old Jew ramp, as the Nazis called it.
往左走。如果你老了、太年轻、有任何虚弱，或者你是一个带着孩子的母亲，你就往左走，你将被带往毒气室。没有人知道会发生这种情况。或者往右走，你将被选为劳工，成为一个纹有编号并被迫劳作的奴隶。为了让这个过程顺利进行，它必须平稳推进。而为了让它平稳推进，犹太人自己绝不能知道等待他们的命运是什么。如果他们知道了，鲁道夫·韦尔巴意识到——他并不天真，不会认为“哦，会有起义和武装反抗”。这些人没有武器，他们的孩子，他们的小孩，当然不会。但可能会引起恐慌。可能会发生踩踏。而鉴于纳粹设计的方法，这将是极其难以处理的。正如你所说，这会把事情搞砸。因此，在那个相当令人毛骨悚然的画面中，鲁迪后来谈到这一点时会说：
Watching these trains arrive, sometimes five a day, often in the dead of night, disgorged of these Jewish prisoners, you know, captives, who were clueless as they got off the train. He would see it with his own eyes that not one of them, in the whole two years he was there, he would say that not one person ever knew what Auschwitz meant or what fate awaited them there. And Jonathan, what your book, I mean, chillingly brings to life is another cliche that is often said about the Holocaust, which is that the process of genocide was industrial. And your description of four, five, six trainloads of deportees arriving every night. The reason why, and you make this, I mean, horribly clear, why they have to be told this, it's not just to increase the kind of sadism going on, but to ensure that they will be processed easily. Because it's clear
“赶羊比猎鹿或捕猪要容易得多。”作为在斯洛伐克乡间长大的孩子，他的意思是，一队走向屠宰场的绵羊是可以控制的，你可以管理庞大的数量。但如果你是一个在山坡上狙击单个鹿的猎人，那需要时间，而且你会错过很多。因此他预见到，如果犹太人到达时就知道自己被带去送死，他们就会恐慌。有些人会这样跑掉，有些人会那样跑掉。是的，他们大部分会被枪杀，但那会是一片混乱。而在那混乱中，有些人可能会活下来。这就是为什么纳粹甚至在毒气室大门锁上的那一刻，还在对俘虏说：现在把自己洗干净，享受洗澡的乐趣吧，等等。他们甚至在最后一刻也不希望发生任何可能减慢速度、可能往机器齿轮里扔沙子的恐慌。
that if there was a riot broke out, it wouldn't just be a problem for the guards that they then have to shoot people, but it would also snarl up the process of genocide. This, I think, was Rudolf Weber's great insight. It struck him. He was a teenager. He's 18 by the time he works on the ramp. But this is exactly what he realises, that he is witnessing an industrialized industrial process, and that the key element of this machine, the key sort of cog in the machine is deception. It isn't an added extra. It is essential. Why? Because for the Nazi process to work, the throughput of people to work, it must move in a smooth, orderly fashion. Those Jews must get off those trains, they must allow themselves to be organized into columns, they must go through the process of
正是这一点促使鲁道夫·韦尔巴做出了至关重要的决定：如果欺骗是这台杀戮机器的核心要素，那么往机器齿轮里扔沙子的唯一方法，就是撕裂欧洲犹太人头顶上的那层无知面纱。这意味着必须有人逃出去，告诉他们奥斯威辛意味着什么，因为他们显然对此一无所知。带着年轻人那种美妙的狂妄，他决定：这个人为什么不能是我呢？就在我们讲到逃跑之前，他正处于能够观察机器运作的位置，因为他在“加拿大”工作。他先是一名助理登记员，然后是集中营文书，对吧？所以汤姆和我之前实际上在私下讨论过这个，对吧？
selection to the left. If you are old or too young or in any way weak or you are a mother with children, you go to the left where you will be taken to the gas chambers. Nobody knows that's what's going to happen. You'll become a prisoner tattooed with a number and forced to work as a slave. For that process to work, it has to proceed smoothly. And for it to proceed smoothly, the Jews themselves cannot possibly know what fate awaits them. If they do, Rudolf Erber realizes, he's not naive enough to think, oh, there'll be an uprising and an armed revolt. These people have no weapons, their children, their kids, of course not. But there might be panic. There could be a stampede. And that would be impossibly hard for the Nazis,
所以这是一个如此艰难的问题，不是吗？那些在“加拿大”工作的人是——用这个词并不准确。所以，好吧，这确实是个不准确的词，但他们是在与机器合作。他们在帮助机器运转，不是吗？像这样的人对此会有道德上的内疚感吗？还是说鲁迪会说：听着，担任集中营文书，
given the method they have devised. It would, as you say, snarl it up. And so in this quite chilling image, he would, Rudi would use when later talking about this, he would say, it is much easier to kill sheep than to hunt pigs or deer. And what he meant by that as a boy who'd grown up in the Slovak countryside was that a column of sheep marching into the abattoir can be handled, you can manage big numbers. But if you are a hunter picking off individual deer on the hillside, that takes time and you will miss a lot. And so what he envisaged was that if Jews arrived knowing they were being led to their deaths, they would then panic. Some would run off in this way. Some would run off in that way. Yes, most of them would be gunned down, but it would be chaos. And in that chaos, some might survive. And so that's why the Nazis, even at the moment when
要么那样做，要么死。这是一个无法选择的处境。还是说他们大多数人依然处于无知状态，所以他们并不认为这是一个道德困境？你说的对，这是一个棘手的问题。你说的很对，或者说有趣的是，鲁迪本人确实对此进行了深刻的思考。我的意思是，在晚年生活中，鲁迪会对奥斯威辛的其他幸存者保持高度警惕，如果他以前不认识他们的话，因为他会想他们为了活下来都做了些什么。说句题外话，弗雷德·韦茨拉尔（Fred Wetzler）——他逃亡时的同伴——娶了一位奥斯威辛幸存者，
the doors are locking of the gas chamber, they are being told by their captors, get yourself clean now, enjoy your shit, enjoy bathing, et cetera. They do not, even at the last moment, want the panic that could slow down, that could throw sand in the gears of the machine. And that is what leads Rudolf Weber to make the crucial decision, which is if deception is the central element of this killing machine, then the only way to throw some sand in the gears of the machine is to tear through that veil of ignorance that the Jews of Europe have. That means somebody has to get out and tell them what Auschwitz means because they clearly don't know. And he decides with that wonderful arrogance of youth, that person might as well be me. Just before we get to the escape, he's in a position to observe the workings of the machine because he's in Canada. He's an assistant registrar and then he's the camp clerk, isn't he? So Tom and I were actually talking about this earlier, weren't we,
弗雷德和鲁迪的关系变得非常紧张，部分原因正是鲁迪对弗雷德的妻子高度怀疑，因为她是一名奥斯威辛幸存者。这是一个非常难以面对的想法，但他会想：你为了活下来都做了什么？按照这个逻辑，你会觉得他也必须审判自己。但他对此并没有道德上的内疚，因为活下去是至关重要的，而且他必须做的工作性质并不涉及让他去勾结杀害犹太人的过程。我的意思是，他不是卡波（Kapos）。不，我的意思是，卡波是党卫军用作执法者和帮凶的看守。其中许多人——有些是犹太人，许多人不是——
between ourselves. So this is such a difficult question, isn't it? Those people who are in Canada are, I mean, it's the wrong word. So, you know, well, it is just the wrong word, but they are collaborating with the machine. They're helping it to work, aren't they? Do people like that have moral qualms about it? Or would Rudolf Seff said, listen, working as the camp clerk,
许多人是从德国监狱转来的囚犯，通常是带有绿三角标记的普通刑事犯，而不是黄星。在奥斯威辛，你还记得一整套按颜色编码的三角形系统：臭名昭著的粉红三角形代表同性恋囚犯，黄星显然代表犹太人，红三角代表政治犯。绿三角会让像鲁迪这样的囚犯感到恐惧，因为那是普通刑事犯，通常是杀人犯，是最残酷的帮凶。党卫军用武器来维持集中营的治安。而卡波，尤其是绿三角那一帮人，则拿着棍棒和木棒。
it was that or die. This is an impossible situation to be in. Or are most of them still ignorant? So they don't think it's a moral dilemma, as it were. You're right, this is a tough question. And it's your right to that, or it's interesting to that Rudy himself really thought about this a lot. I mean, in later life, Rudy would be very suspicious of fellow survivors of Auschwitz if he didn't already know them, because he would wonder what did they do to survive. You know, jumping ahead, Fred Wetzler, who is his partner in escape, married a survivor of Auschwitz
他们会把“能不能一拳打死一个囚犯”当作运动比赛。你知道，鲁迪亲眼目睹过这一点。一拳击倒并打死一名犹太囚犯。他们并不觉得自己做的事和那有什么两样。相反，他们依然是集中营里的奴隶。与被命令去扛水泥不同，他们的工作——我们这里应该区分一下，因为“加拿大”
and relations between Fred and Rudy became very strained, in part because Rudy was very suspicious of Fred's wife, because she was an Auschwitz survivor. A very difficult thought to grapple with, but he thought, what did you do to survive? Now, by that logic, you would think he would have to judge himself. He didn't have moral qualms about that because survival was essential and the nature of the work he had to do did not involve him in having to collude in the process of killing Jews. I mean, there were. He's not a capo. No, I mean, so capos were guards who were used as sort of enforcers and henchmen by the SS. And many of them, some were Jews, many of them were not,
是一份具体的工作，意味着你在仓库里，但还有其他的工作，比如当登记员或文书。听着，从某种程度上你可以说他们让集中营的齿轮转动了，他们让这个机器得以运转，因此从某种程度上你可以提出多米尼克所指出的指控。但他们的看法，当然我认为也是鲁迪的看法，是他们参与了
many of them were prisoners who had been moved from German jails, often common criminals with marked by a green triangle rather than the yellow star. In Auschwitz, you remember a whole colour coded system of triangles, pink triangles famously for gay prisoners, yellow star obviously for Jews, reds for political prisoners. Green triangle would put the fear of God into a prisoner like Rudy, because that was a common criminal, often murderers, who were the most brutal henchmen. The SS would police the camp with weapons. The capos, the Green Triangle crowd especially, would carry clubs and sticks.
抵抗事业。他得到的那份工作——集中营文书、营房文书（这是他的原话），作为助理登记员——他得到这份工作是因为地下组织，奥斯威辛的抵抗组织……多米尼克，就像你刚才一开始所说的，你意识到所有这些你以前不知道的关于奥斯威辛的事情——其实我也是第一次听说奥斯威辛存在一个组织严密的抵抗运动和地下组织。
And they would have, for sport competitions, could you kill a prisoner in a single blow? You know, Rudy witnessed that. To, you know, a single punch to knock out and kill a Jewish prisoner. They did not see what they were doing as anything like that. Rather, they were still slaves in the camp. And instead of being told to, you know, carry cement, their job, and we should distinguish here because Canada
他们为自己人在那些地方争取到了工作。其中许多人是非犹太籍的德国政治犯，但越来越多的犹太囚犯也能够担任这些角色。正因为他身处那个职位，他部分地得以幸存。他获得了更多的配粮。他能够穿自己的衣服。他还拥有一份能够让他真正看清到底发生了什么的工作。但为了向你展示鲁迪对多米尼克提出的问题的清醒程度，他对地下组织感到沮丧，因为他看到他们非常努力地在改善自己的条件，他们通过贿赂和勒索党卫军看守的组合拳非常有效地做到了这一点。他们确实有效地提高了自己在奥斯威辛的生活质量，甚至还有预期寿命。集中营里的存活率确实上升了。与此同时，紧挨着奥斯威辛集中营的就是死亡集中营、毒气室和焚尸炉，而那里的屠杀仍在以巨大的速度持续着。鲁迪以一个非常年轻的人所具备的那种极大的清晰度意识到的事情是：嗯，从一个非常反常的角度来看，这个死亡率正在下降的集中营的顺利运转，实际上对死亡集中营产生了连锁反应，因为每当有新的运输车到达时，过去他们必须从新到达的人中挑选5%或10%来维持集中营的运转。现在他们根本不需要新人了，因为劳改营里的人
was a specific job, meaning you were in the warehouses, but there were these other jobs to be registrars or pen pushers. Look, on some level, you could say they enabled the wheels of the concentration camp to turn, They allowed the thing to function and therefore on some level that you could make the charge that Dominic raised. Their view, and certainly I think Rudy's view, was that they were engaged
活得更久了。因此，现在到达的那些犹太人，有95%、97%、98%都被直接送往毒气室。所以他把话说得很严厉。他说，你知道，他意识到抵抗运动，如果在任何方面有所影响的话，那就是允许更多犹太人在死亡集中营部分被杀害。因此他开始思考：听着，我很高兴抵抗运动在改善囚犯的生活，我自己也从中受益。但这还不够。从道德上讲，这是不可接受的。我们必须从事的任务是制止死亡集中营和毒气室里的杀戮。正因如此，他下定决心必须逃跑，并警告欧洲的犹太人。而且他是最适合做这件事的人，因为他亲眼目睹了死亡集中营的运作。
in the business of resistance, that he got the job he got as a pen pusher, barracks pen pusher was his phrase, as an assistant registrar. He got that job because the underground, the Aus ashford resistance and again you know dominic at the beginning you were saying how you realized all these things about us that you didn't know i mean it was news to me that there was a really organized auschwitz resistance and underground
在抵抗运动中，他得到了他所从事的工作，一个文书，兵营文书，这是他的原话，作为一名助理书记官。他得到这份工作是因为地下组织，奥斯威辛抵抗组织，就像你说的，多米尼克，一开始你提到你是如何意识到所有这些关于我们的事情是你不知道的，我的意思是，对于我来说这也是个新闻，奥斯威辛居然有一个组织得很好的抵抗运动和地下组织
they got secured jobs for their people in those places a lot of them were non-jewish german political prisoners but increasingly jewish prisoners were also able to get those roles secured jobs for their people in those places. A lot of them were non-Jewish German political prisoners, but increasingly Jewish prisoners were also able to get those roles. And it was because he was in that role that he was able partly to survive. He got more rations. He was able to wear his own clothes. He also had this, a job that enabled him to really see what was going on. But just to show you how alive Rudy was to the issue that Dominic raises, he became frustrated with the underground because he saw that they were working very hard to improve their own conditions, which they did very effectively through a combination of bribery and
他们在那些地方为自己的人争取到了安全的工作岗位，其中许多人是非犹太裔的德国政治犯，但越来越多的犹太犯人也能够获得这些角色，为自己的人在那些地方争取到安全的工作岗位。许多人是非犹太裔德国政治犯，但越来越的犹太犯人也能够获得这些角色。正因为他处于那个角色，他才部分地得以生存。他得到了更多的配给。他能够穿自己的衣服。他还有这份工作，使他能够真正了解发生了什么。但为了向你展示鲁迪对多米尼克提出的问题的敏锐程度，他对地下组织感到沮丧，因为他看到他们正在非常努力地改善他们自己的状况，他们通过贿赂和敲诈SS卫兵的组合非常有效地做到了这一点。
blackmail of their SS guards. They effectively did increase not just the quality of life, but their life expectancy in Auschwitz. The concentration camp did rise. Meanwhile, adjoining the Auschwitz concentration camp is the death camp, the gas chambers, the crematoria, and that is continuing at a huge pace. And what Rudy realizes, again, with that great clarity that he seems to have as a very young man is, well, in a very perverse way, the smooth functioning of this concentration camp, where the death rate is now falling, is actually having a knock-on effect on the death camp, because every time a new transport arrives, in the past, they used to have to pick off 5% or 10% of the new arrivals to keep the concentration camp running. Now they just don't need any new people because people are
他们实际上不仅提高了生活质量，还提高了他们在奥斯威辛的预期寿命。集中营确实上升了。与此同时，与奥斯威辛集中营毗邻的是死亡营，毒气室，火葬场，这正以惊人的速度继续着。鲁迪再次意识到，凭借他作为一个非常年轻的人似乎具有的那种极大的清晰度，嗯，用一种非常反常的方式，这个集中营的顺利运转，死亡率现在正在下降，实际上对死亡营产生了连锁反应，因为每当有新的运输队到达时，过去，他们必须挑出新到达人员的5%或10%来维持集中营的运转。现在他们根本不需要任何新的人，因为人们在奴隶劳改营里活得更久了。
living longer in the slave labor camp. And therefore, those Jews who are arriving now are sent directly, 95%, 97%, 98% to the gas chambers. So he puts it very harshly. And he says, you know, he realized that the resistance was, you know, if anything, allowing more Jews to be killed in the death camp part. And so he begins to think, look, I'm glad that resistance is making life better for prisoners. I myself am benefiting from it. But that is not good enough. Morally, that is not acceptable. The task we have to engage in is stopping the killing in the death camp and in the gas chambers. And that's why he becomes resolved that he must escape and warn the Jews of Europe. And he is ideally qualified to do that because he has witnessed the functioning of the death camp.
因此，现在到达的那些犹太人被直接送往，95%，97%，98%送到毒气室。所以他说的非常严厉。他说，你知道，他意识到抵抗运动，如果有什么不同的话，就是允许更多的犹太人在死亡营部分被杀害。因此，他开始思考，看吧，我很高兴抵抗运动让囚犯的生活变得更好。我自己也从中受益。但这还不够。在道德上，这是不可接受的。我们必须从事的任务是停止在死亡营和毒气室中的杀戮。这就是为什么他下定决心，他必须逃跑并警告欧洲的犹太人。他具备这样做的理想资格，因为他亲眼目睹了死亡营的运作。
He has seen how it's ignorance on the part of the deportees of their fate that enables them to be processed. And he is intellectually brilliant. And before, you know, back when he's in Slovakia, in the village, he's been deprived of his education. You have this incredibly moving detail about how they find an old chemistry book, him and a friend, and they kind of study it as though it's the most precious thing in the world. And so he is used to memorizing things. And that makes him a kind of, you know, a living compendium of information about Auschwitz. And so that he feels, you know, he has the personal stake in escaping, but also that he will be doing a great service, that he will be saving his thousands, hundreds of thousands, perhaps millions in his dreams
他注意到，正是由于被驱逐者对自己的命运一无所知，才使得他们能够被有条不紊地处理掉。而且他有着极高的智商。在此之前，你知道的，当他在斯洛伐克的村庄里时，他曾被剥夺了受教育的权利。你甚至会听到一个令人无比动容的细节：他和朋友找到了一本旧化学书，然后他们像对待世上最珍贵的东西一样去钻研它。因此，他习惯于背诵事物。这使他成为了一个关于奥斯威辛的、活生生的信息宝库。所以他觉得自己一方面有逃跑的个人利害关系，另一方面他也认为自己是在做一件伟大的善事，在梦中他能拯救成千上万、数十万甚至数百万
of people. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when hundreds of thousands, perhaps millions in his dreams of people. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, perhaps we could talk about his escape, whether it were, you know, whether he how many people he managed to save and the kind of the long term consequences of Auschwitz on his life. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
的人。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当成千上万、数十万甚至数百万人在他的梦中被拯救时，我想我们现在应该休息一下。等我们回来时，也许我们可以谈谈他的逃生，比如他是如何做到的，他成功拯救了多少人，以及奥斯威辛对他人生产生的长期影响。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩下的全部》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量娱乐圈八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Jonathan, we began the first half. Tom read the first few sentences of your book, The Escape Artist. So that was April 1944. It's Rudolph Walter's great moment. So take us through the escape. What's the plan? Because the plan is, you know, it's phenomenally clever, isn't it?
如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史剩下的全部》。乔纳森，我们开始了上半场。汤姆宣读了你的书《逃脱艺术家》的前几句话。那是1944年4月。这是鲁道夫·沃特辉煌的时刻。那么，带我们了解一下这次逃亡吧。计划是什么？因为这个计划，你知道的，非常聪明，对吧？
It is. It's really ingenious. It rests on their identification of a gap in the Nazi defences. And it's not a physical gap. It's not like they've discovered there's a hole in a fence somewhere. Rather, and this is where it's his great brain that is so important, he and his escape partner, Fred Wetzler, discover there is a flaw in the Nazi method. And it turns on, in a way, the Nazis' great strength, which is their loyal fidelity to routine, their very predictability. I'm going to hold back the exact way they do it because I am quite keen for people to read the book. Suffice it to say, I'm guessing like you two and men of our generation, I have read a lot of World War II escape stories. We've seen the movies, etc. To me, this is the most thrilling of all of them and that's
是的。确实非常巧妙。它建立在他们发现纳粹防线漏洞的基础上。这不是物理上的漏洞，并不是说他们在某处栅栏上发现了一个洞。相反——这就是他那伟大的大脑如此重要的地方——他和他的逃亡伙伴弗雷德·维茨勒发现纳粹的方法中存在一个缺陷。这在某种程度上取决于纳粹最大的优势，那就是他们对常规的忠诚以及高度的可预测性。我打算保留他们具体的做法，因为我很希望人们去读这本书。简而言之，我猜就像你们两个以及我们这一代人一样，我读过很多二战逃亡的故事。我们看过电影等等。对我来说，这是所有故事中最惊心动魄的一个，这
partly because it is the hardest possible escape to mount because jews were held more tightly than anyone else it's you know um there were escapes of soviet political soviet prisoners of war from auschwitz and of polish political prisoners but jews uh they're a grand total of five ever made it out. One was taken out by an SS man. I tell the story in the book, which is a sort of very exceptional story. It happened the day before Rudolf's escape. But in terms of engineering your own escape, Rudolf Erber and his friend Fred Wetzler are the very first to do it. And it turns on that idea that they have seen a flaw, that in the Nazi routine, there is a way of turning that method against them. And it requires great physical resilience. It will see the two of them, as you heard from those
部分是因为这是最难发起的逃亡，因为犹太人被控制得比任何人都严。你知道的，嗯，曾经有苏联政治犯、苏联战俘以及波兰政治犯从奥斯威辛逃跑的记录，但犹太人——总共只有五个人成功逃出。其中一个是被一个党卫军带出去的。我在书中讲了这个故事，这是一个非常特殊的事件。它发生在鲁道夫逃跑的前一天。但就自己策划逃亡而言，鲁道夫·埃伯和他的朋友弗雷德·维茨勒是绝对的第一批。这取决于他们的那个想法：他们看到了一个漏洞，在纳粹的常规中，有一种方法可以把这种方法反过来对付他们。这需要极大的身体韧性。正如你从那些
introductory paragraphs, essentially hiding in a hole in the ground for three days and three nights in a space not much bigger than a double grave, the two men side by side. They will have to do that in order to outwit the kind of security protocols that the Nazis have imposed specifically on Jewish prisoners. It is so ingenious and incredibly, it does mean that on April the 10th, 1944, they emerge in the dead of night, in the darkness, and reach the outer perimeter of Auschwitz and are able to wriggle out of that fence. And suddenly, they're out. And so, Jonathan, he's armed himself with two things, I think.
导言段落中听到的那样，这两个人基本上要在地下一个仅比双人墓穴稍大的空间里，肩并肩地在土洞里躲藏三天三夜。为了智胜纳粹专门针对犹太囚犯实施的那套安全协议，他们必须这样做。这太巧妙了，而且令人难以置信的是，这意味着在1944年4月10日，他们在深夜的黑暗中浮出地面，到达了奥斯威辛的外围，并设法从那个栅栏里钻了出去。突然之间，他们逃出来了。所以，乔纳森，我认为他为自己准备了两样东西。
And the first is a scrap of the page of a children's atlas that he had found back in Canada, which shows him how to get from Auschwitz to the Slovak border. Basically, you follow the line of a river. And the second thing is that he'd met a Russian prisoner of war who gave him a lot of very, very firm advice about what you do when you escape. Don't trust anyone, all kinds of things. Can you just describe what it is that he gets from that Russian prisoner of war? Because should anyone need to escape, it might provide some kind of useful tips. It's quite right. As soon as Rudy had made
第一件是他在加拿大找到的儿童地图集的一页残片，它向他展示了如何从奥斯威辛到达斯洛伐克边境。基本上，你顺着一条河流走就行了。第二件事是，他遇到过一个俄罗斯战俘，对方给了他很多非常非常坚定的建议，关于逃跑时该怎么做。不要相信任何人，诸如此类。你能描述一下他从那个俄罗斯战俘那里得到了什么吗？因为如果有人需要逃跑，这可能会提供一些有用的提示。完全正确。鲁迪一旦做出
the decision, I've got to escape, he does become this kind of student of escape. And as you said, he was very used to being self-taught. He'd already done that even before Auschwitz, because he, from age 14 onwards, couldn't go to school anymore. So he was used to that. He was armed also with a friend, and that's very important. In Fred Wetzler, he had found a companion who he trusted. The two of them trusted each other. And that's because, I'm convinced of this, that they were from the same hometown. They had known each other before Auschwitz. Very difficult to trust somebody who you'd only known in this upside down, morally inverted realm of Auschwitz-Birkenau, where good is bad and black is white and day is night. You couldn't
“我必须逃跑”的决定，他就成为了这种逃跑学问的研究者。正如你所说，他非常习惯自学。甚至在奥斯威辛之前他就已经这样做了，因为他从14岁起就无法再去上学。所以他对此习以为常。他还带着一个朋友，这一点非常重要。在弗雷德·维茨勒身上，他找到了一个他信任的同伴。他们俩互相信任。这是因为——我对此深信不疑——他们来自同一个家乡。他们在奥斯威辛之前就认识对方。很难去信任一个你只在奥斯威辛-比克瑙这个颠倒的、道德错位的国度里认识的人，在那里好是坏、黑是白、日是夜。你不可能
be sure of someone who you'd only known there. But he knew Alfred Wetzler from Terneva in Slovakia, six years older than him. So he was armed with that. He was armed, as you say, with this memory. He'd had to commit it to memory, this image of the map that he'd seen very briefly in a children's atlas in Canada. That told him at least where he was in the world. Oswiecim, the nearest town to Auschwitz. He'd seen that on the map and worked out, OK, I need to go 90 to 100 kilometers, about 90 kilometers to reach the border with Slovakia. And he was armed with these extraordinary, as you put it, this compendium of facts. He'd memorized every transport, every date,
对一个只在那里认识的人放心。但他认识来自斯洛伐克特尔内瓦的阿尔弗雷德·维茨勒，他比他大六岁。所以他带着这些。正如你所说，他带着这种记忆。他必须把它牢记在心，这是他在加拿大的儿童地图集里非常短暂地看过的地图的影像。那至少告诉了他他在世界上的位置。奥斯威辛，离奥斯威辛最近的城镇。他在地图上看到了那个地方，并计算出：好的，我需要走90到100公里，大约90公里才能到达与斯洛伐克的边境。他带着这些非凡的——正如你所说——事实宝库。他记住了每一次运输、每一个日期、
every point of origin, a freakish feat of memory that he'd done. But otherwise, he did feel as if he came out of there with nothing because he had no map, as he put it, no map, no compass, no friends. There was no network, no resistance network outside Auschwitz ready to greet Jewish escapees. There were, if you were in the Polish resistance or if you were a Soviet prisoner of war, there were people outside who might help you. But he was in Nazi-occupied Poland. He and Fred were there, where at any turn there could be Wehrmacht, you know, German soldiers.
每一个出发点，这是一项惊人的记忆壮举。但除此之外，他确实觉得空手从那里出来了，因为正如他所说，他没有地图、没有指南针、没有朋友。没有外部网络，没有奥斯威辛外部准备迎接犹太逃亡者的抵抗网络。如果你在波兰抵抗组织里，或者如果你是苏联战俘，外面可能会有人帮助你。但他身处纳粹占领的波兰。他和弗雷德在那里，随时都可能遇到国防军，也就是
They do encounter them at one point. There could be Volksdeutsche, you know, ethnic Germans settled there. And there could be Poles who were collaborating with the Nazis. So danger everywhere. But he did have in his head the sort of course in escapology that had been taught to him by this man, Dmitry Volkov, a Ukrainian actually, formerly a captain in the Red Army and a prisoner in Auschwitz, who took a long time to win his trust, but told him things like, you know, do not move during the day. You can only go at night. You sleep during the day, you move at night. Don't have money.
德国士兵——他们在某个时候确实遇到了。那里还可能有德意志裔人，也就是定居在那里的族裔德国人。还可能有与纳粹合作的波兰人。所以到处都是危险。但他脑子里确实有一门逃跑学的课程，是由这个人教给他的，这个人叫德米特里·沃尔科夫，实际上是个乌克兰人，曾是红军的一名上尉，也是奥斯威辛的囚犯。他花了很长时间才赢得他的信任，但告诉了他一些事情，比如：白天不要移动。你只能在夜间行动。你白天睡觉，晚上行动。不要有钱。
Don't even accept money because you have money, you'll be tempted to spend it. And by spending it, that means it will take you into a village and you'll be spotted. You've got to stay away from other people. You know, foraging for food. You've, you know, avoiding meat because the smell of it could attract animals. You know, all kinds of tips, even, and this is the thing I think captures people's imagination most. It certainly captured mine when I came across this detail when I was 19. But when you're in hiding, he said, you need to sprinkle around your hiding place tobacco, not just any tobacco, but machorka, a form of very cheap Russian tobacco that has been soaked in gasoline and then dried. He says, don't tell me why, but the smell of that repels the SS sniffer dogs and the sort of bloodhounds that will be chasing you.
甚至不要接受钱，因为如果你有钱，你就会经不住诱惑去花它。而花钱意味着你会走进村庄，然后你就会被发现。你必须远离其他人。比如为了食物去觅食。比如避免吃肉，因为肉的气味会吸引动物。各种各样的建议，甚至——我认为这是最能激发人们想象力的东西。当我19岁时偶然发现这个细节时，它确实激发了我的想象力。但他说，当你躲藏时，你需要在你的藏身处周围撒上烟草，不要随便什么烟草，而是马霍尔卡（machorka），一种浸泡在汽油中然后晒干的非常便宜的俄罗斯烟草。他说，别问我为什么，但那个气味会排斥党卫军的嗅探犬以及会追捕你们的猎犬。
I mean, this level of detail was taught to him by this Red Army captain. And so, you know, they had a lot of know-how. They had ridiculous physical bravery. He was just 19. Fred was 25. And somehow in those, it's about 10 or 11 days afterwards, doing as they were told, traveling in the night, They crossed forests and rivers and mountains and marshlands, going through hostile territory, Nazi-occupied Poland.
我的意思是，这种级别的细节是由这位红军上尉教给他的。所以，你知道的，他们有很多诀窍。他们有着荒谬的身体勇气。他当时只有19岁，弗雷德25岁。不知何故，在随后的那大约10到11天里，他们按照指示在夜间赶路，穿过了森林、河流、山脉和沼泽，穿过了充满敌意的领土——纳粹占领的波兰。
I mean, it wasn't the same as Auschwitz, but it wasn't easy for a Jew on the run. Their feet swell, they get injured. At one point, they come under fire, they have to cross through ice and snow at one point. But somehow, they they have pulled off what at that point nobody else had ever done before. They were the first Jews ever to have engineered their own escape from Auschwitz-Birkenau and to have made their way successfully to freedom. And their plan. So they have a plan, don't they? A larger scheme, which is they're going to tell the world and save Jews that way. So here's the slightly complicated thing.
我的意思是，这和奥斯威辛不一样，但对于一个逃亡的犹太人来说也绝非易事。他们的脚肿了，受伤了。在某个时刻，他们遭到枪击，在某个时刻他们不得不穿过冰雪。但不知何故，他们完成了当时以前任何人从未做过的事情。他们是第一批策划自己从奥斯威辛-比克瑙逃亡并成功走向自由的犹太人。他们的计划。所以他们有一个计划，对吧？一个更大的宏伟计划，那就是他们要将真相告诉世界，以此拯救犹太人。所以这里有一点复杂的情况。
There is a state-approved Jewish center in Slovakia. That's right, isn't it? The UZ? I know I should be pronouncing that differently. That's right. No, no, that's right. There's the Jewish center or, in effect, Jewish council is being used by the Nazis.
在斯洛伐克有一个国家批准的犹太人中心。没错吧？就是UZ？我知道我应该用不同的方式发音。没错。不，不，没错。犹太人中心，或者实际上是犹太人委员会，正被纳粹所利用。
They did this everywhere. The Nazis would, every time they were in charge, and the fascist authorities in Slovakia did the same, they would make sure their instructions were passed to the Jewish communities by the Jewish community leadership. And they would say to the Jewish community elders, you know, it's your choice. Either we do it and you can see that we will do it brutally or you do it and maybe you get to soften the blow in some way. So, you know, you draw up the lists of everybody you have between the ages of 16 and 30. And if you don't, we'll just pull people out of their houses and they would demonstrate that that's how they would do it. And so this was a terrible moral dilemma. I mean, the most awful predicament. Do we do the devil's work or do we let the devil do his work unfettered? And the
他们在到处都这样做。每当纳粹当权时，斯洛伐克的法西斯当局也是如此，他们都会确保他们的指示是通过犹太社区领导层传达给犹太社区的。他们会向犹太社区的长老们说，你知道的，这是你的选择。要么由我们来做，你可以看到我们会残忍地做；要么由你来做，也许你还能以某种方式减轻打击。所以，你知道的，你们拟定一份你们拥有的所有16岁到30岁之间的人的名单。如果你不这么做，我们就会直接把人从家里拉出来，并且他们会用实际行动证明他们就是这么做的。这是一个可怕的道德困境。我的意思是，最糟糕的困境。我们是去做魔鬼的工作，还是让魔鬼不受束缚地做他的工作？而斯洛伐克的
Jewish leadership in Slovakia made the, you know, not all of them, some wouldn't go along with it, but they made a decision to do it. And Walter Rudy hugely resented them, actually, because the order, for example, to turn up that initial deportation order, it came, as it were, on Jewish community headed notepaper, and he wrote on their letterhead, you know, And he remembered that and thought, well, you know, how can I possibly trust these people with the information I have and yet didn't really know who else to bring it to? What he didn't know was that within the official Jewish leadership, a large group of that same body of people were also engaged in resistance activities, and they called themselves the working group, and they were also engaged in illicit underground activities. So these were the sorts of hideous moral dilemmas that people were thrown into, where you can see with your own eyes that your fellow Jews are going to be bundled on trains and deported.
犹太领导层做出了——并不是所有人，有些人不同意，但他们做出了去做的决定。事实上，沃尔特·鲁迪对此非常怨恨，因为例如那份最初的驱逐令，它是印在犹太社区信头信纸上的，他在信头上写道……他对此记忆犹新，并心想，好吧，我怎么能把掌握的信息托付给这些人呢？然而又不知道还能把这些信息带给谁。他所不知道的是，在官方犹太领导层内部，同一批人中的很大一部分人也参与了抵抗活动，他们称自己为“工作小组”，也从事非法的地下活动。这就是人们陷入的那种可怕的道德困境，你亲眼看着同胞犹太人被捆绑上火车并被驱逐出境。
Do you allow that to happen brutally or do you allow it to happen where you have some hand in it and perhaps can dilute the edict somewhere? None of us can know what we would decide. None of us can judge, I don't think, what was right or wrong in that situation. Rudy himself was very judgmental and judged those people very harshly for what they did. But he does make contact through an amazing series of scrapes, really, you know, at one point involving he and Fred dressing up as Slovak sort of pig herds and helping transport a farmer, a good man who helps them. They dress up as his pig herds and bundle a whole lot of pigs onto a train and thereby go to a local regional meat market, livestock market, and there make contact with a Jewish doctor who leads them to the Jewish, underground Jewish leadership. And from there, they are transferred to a small town of Zhilina, where, and I've stood in this room, they're in
你是任由这一切残忍地发生，还是让它在你有一定插手、或许能在某种程度上冲淡法令的情况下发生？我们谁也不知道自己会做出什么决定。我认为，在那种情况下，我们谁也无法判断什么是对是错。鲁迪本人非常有批判性，对那些人所做的事情做出了严厉的评判。但他确实通过一系列惊险的经历取得了联系，你知道的，在某个时刻，他和弗雷德装扮成斯洛伐克的猪倌，帮忙运送一个好心的农夫，那个农夫帮助了他们。他们伪装成他的猪倌，把一大群猪赶上火车，从而去了当地的区域肉类市场、牲口市场，并在那里联系到了一位犹太医生，后者引领他们找到了地下的犹太领导层。从那里，他们被转移到了日利纳的小镇，——我曾站在那个房间里，他们待在
the basement of the Jewish old people's home in Zilina, for the best part of a fortnight, they are in secret, in hiding, debriefed. And there has to be in hiding, these are now wanted men. And I reproduce in the book, the SS Gestapo telegram. The telegram goes from the SS to the Gestapo saying, you know, these men are on the run and are wanted. And this would have been put up on the bulletin board of every Gestapo office across the Nazi empire, across Europe, you know, Walter Israel Rosenberg and Alfred Israel Wetzler. The Nazis insisted that every Jewish man, if his first name was not identifiably Jewish, adopted the name Israel as a middle name.
日利纳犹太人老龄之家的地下室里，长达将近两周的时间，他们在秘密隐藏中接受盘问。必须躲藏起来，因为他们现在是通缉犯。我在书中复制了党卫军盖世太保的电报。这份电报从党卫军发给盖世太保，上面写着，你知道的，这些人正在逃亡并遭到通缉。这会被贴在纳粹帝国、整个欧洲每个盖世太保办公室的公告栏上，你知道的，沃尔特·以色列·罗森堡和阿尔弗雷德·以色列·维茨勒。纳粹坚持要求每个犹太男子，如果他的名字无法明显看出是犹太人的话，都要把“以色列”作为中间名采用。
And so you see that in this telegram. But there in hiding, the information they have gathered pours out of them. They cannot stop. two years, the estimated number, the point of origin, and even the sort of serial number allocated to the handful of prisoners on each transport who were selected to live and become slave laborers, those numbers that are famously tattooed on the arm. So he a transport from, say, you know, Grodno in Poland in August of 1943 or whatever. He's memorized them all. And so every word that comes out of them is taken down as if in dictation by a man who works for the Jewish leadership. And he writes a very dry, strictly factual, 32-page, single-spaced account of what's happened.
所以你在这份电报中看到了这一点。但在藏匿处，他们收集的信息如倾盆大雨般涌出。他们停不下来。两年时间，估计的人数，出发点，甚至分配给每次运输中被挑选出来活下来并成为苦工的少数囚犯的序列号——那些在手臂上有名的刺青数字。所以他能说出，比方说，1943年8月来自波兰格罗德诺的运送……他把这些都背了下来。因此，他们说出的每一个字都被一个为犹太领导层工作的人像听写一样记录下来。他写了一份非常枯燥、严格基于事实、单倍行距、共32页的关于所发生事情的叙述。
Reading your account of it, you say that it describes so much that Auschwitz conjures up. The life of an Auschwitz prisoner, the topography of the camps, the initial journey by cattle truck, the shaving of heads and bodies, the tattooing of numbers, the colour-coded triangles, the barracks, the inner and outer
读了你对它的记述，你说它描述了奥斯威辛所唤起的大量内容。奥斯威辛囚犯的生活、集中营的地形、乘坐运牛卡车初次抵达、剃光头发和身体、刺青编号、色标三角形、营房、内外
chain of watchtowers, the roll call, the sign saying Arbyte McFry, the slave factories, the hanging of attempted escapees, the starvation, the casual beatings, all of it. So all of that is in there. But I was startled when you say that the word gas didn't appear until page seven. And its core revelation that all but a small number of jewish deportees for auschwitz were murdered on arrival didn't come until page eight so i mean that's it's again it's this kind of weird combination of the i mean the unbelievable horror of what is being described and yet evidently this kind of almost bureaucratic, punctilious attention to detail. I think that's probably on Oskar Krasniansky,
岗楼链条、点名、写着“劳动带来自由”的标语、血汗工厂、绞死企图逃跑的人、饥饿、随意的殴打，应有尽有。所以所有这些都在里面。但当你说“毒气”这个词直到第七页才出现时，我感到很震惊。而它的核心揭露——即除少数人外，所有被运送到奥斯威辛的犹太被驱逐者在抵达时都被谋杀了——直到第八页才出现，所以我的意思是，这又是一种奇怪的组合，一方面是所描述内容令人难以置信的恐怖，另一方面显然是这种近乎官僚主义的、一丝不苟的细节关注。我想这大概要归功于奥斯卡·克拉斯尼安斯基，
who compiles the report. He's no writer, and he's no journalist, and he doesn't order the verbatim words that have come out of these two young men in the way that I think any of us would. Instead, oddly, he decides to sort of frame it chronologically. So each one, Wetzler and then Werber, describe chronologically what happened to them, starting with their arrival in the transit camps, Novaki in Slovakia, in Rudi's case, and Sereb in Wetzler's case.
他汇编了这份报告。他不是作家，也不是记者，他并没有按照我认为我们任何人都会采用的方式，去整理这两个年轻人说出的原话。相反，奇怪的是，他决定按时间顺序来构建它。因此，无论是维茨勒还是韦伯，每个人都按时间顺序描述了他们身上发生的事情，从他们抵达中转营开始——鲁迪的情况是斯洛伐克的诺瓦基，维茨勒的情况是塞雷德。
And that's why it partly takes you till page seven before you actually get the kind of the lead you know and it's very it's frustrating to read in that sense because you just want to you think it should grab the reader by the scruff of the neck i think what was going on there was in a sense and awareness that this will be unbelievable to people reading it and therefore if you start with the sort of headline, as it were, it would be too easily dismissed. And therefore, it needed to be assembled sort of methodically, where, you know, it's first one fact, then the next fact, then the next until they build. And, you know, between them, Oskar Krasniansky, who compiles the report, he's actually an engineer, and his boss in the Jewish
这就是为什么直到第七页你才真正得到那种头条新闻，从这个意义上说读起来很令人沮丧，因为你只想——你认为它应该揪住读者的衣领。我认为当时的情况在某种程度上是一种意识，即阅读它的人会觉得这令人难以置信，因此如果你以某种头条新闻开头，它就会太容易被驳回。因此，它需要以某种有条理的方式组装起来，你知道的，首先是一个事实，然后是下一个事实，再下一个，直到它们建立起来。你知道的，他们两人之间，汇编报告的奥斯卡·克拉斯尼安斯基实际上是一名工程师，他在犹太
council, Oskar Neumann, is a lawyer. And so between them, an engineer and a lawyer, neither of these are people interested in telling a sort of gripping story. They are rather interested in presenting a chronological sequence of facts and a kind of anatomy of this factory of death, which is something nobody has ever known in human history before. And so this document is drawn up and who does it go to and what is their reaction? So the report is finally finished and it embarks on a journey of its own, almost in a kind of escape journey of its own. And I think my book is the first time in one place that's ever been assembled, the actual route it took. It is a gripping yarn, I think, in its own right, because it has to be smuggled hand to hand across borders, across occupied Europe. Anybody
委员会的老板奥斯卡·诺伊曼是一名律师。所以他们两人之间，一个工程师和一个律师，这两个人都对讲一个引人入胜的故事不感兴趣。他们更感兴趣的是呈现一系列按时间顺序排列的事实，以及这个死亡工厂的解剖结构，这是人类历史上以前任何人从未知道过的东西。因此，这份报告起草出来了，它会发给谁？他们的反应是什么？这份报告终于完成了，它踏上了一段属于它自己的旅程，几乎就像是一次它自己的逃亡之旅。我想我的书是第一次把它的实际路线汇编在一个地方。我认为它本身就是一个引人入胜的故事，因为它必须在被占领的欧洲各地跨越边界，手手相传。任何
who's found holding this thing would immediately themselves be, you know, imprisoned or worse by the Nazis. And so it's a very dangerous document and how it gets smuggled across Europe is to me riveting where, you know, I have the account of a woman who, you know, is literally in a kind of garret in an attic, is secretly translating it into Hungarian. You know, there are figures in the resistance who meet each other at an art gallery and smuggle one copy's surreptitiously moved from the briefcase of one resistance man into the briefcase of the other so that no one will see the handoff of the documents. You know, this is a red hot piece, document that has to be handled with great care, improbably, incredibly, through a whole procession of sometimes ridiculous characters, it finds its way to the desk of
被发现持有这东西的人都会立即被纳粹关进监狱甚至更糟。所以这是一份非常危险的文件，它是如何被走私过欧洲的，对这我感到着迷，你知道的，我有一个女人的叙述，她字面意思上是在阁楼的一个天窗下，秘密地把它翻译成匈牙利语。你知道的，抵抗运动中的一些人物在一个艺术画廊里见面，秘密地将一份复印件从一个抵抗战士的公文包转移到另一个抵抗战士的公文包里，这样就没有人会看到文件的交接。你知道的，这是一个炽热的文件，必须小心翼翼地处理，难以置信地，通过一连串有时荒谬的角色，它最终送达了
Winston Churchill in London, of Franklin Roosevelt in Washington, and Pope Pius in Rome, you know, we have the margin scrawl of Winston Churchill in the summary of the document that reaches him where he writes, what can be done, what can be said, as if rendered almost speechless by what he has seen. That's one way of reading that. Brilliant. Well, I think we should take a break there with the report having reached the desks, I should say, of Winston Churchill and Franklin D. Roosevelt. And maybe, Jonathan, you'll join us again next time to talk about what happens to the report, how the Allies respond, what happens to Rudolf. And then we can chat a little bit, I think, about how we talk about Auschwitz and the Holocaust and a single person's experience. So lots to talk about,
伦敦温斯顿·丘吉尔、华盛顿富兰克林·罗斯福以及罗马教皇庇护的办公桌上，你知道的，我们在到达丘吉尔手中的文件摘要的边缘看到了温斯顿·丘吉尔潦草的字迹，他在上面写道：能做什么，能说什么，仿佛被他所看到的一切震惊得几乎说不出话来。那是解读这一幕的一种方式。太棒了。好吧，我想我们应该在那里休息一下，此时报告已经送达了温斯顿·丘吉尔和富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福的办公桌。也许，乔纳森，下次你能再次加入我们，谈谈这份报告发生了什么，盟友是如何反应的，鲁道夫发生了什么。然后我想我们可以聊聊我们如何谈论奥斯威辛、大屠杀以及单个人的经历。所以有很多要谈的，
and we will see you on The Rest is History next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
我们下次在《历史剩下的全部》中见。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史剩下的全部》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩下的全部》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量娱乐圈八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。